i like video games but you know what
they all have in common they're video
games that's right not real life if this
is the first time you're hearing that
i'm sorry to be the one to break it to
you the point is video games are all
experienced through video tvs monitors
cell phone screens all of which emit
blue light which can lead to all sorts
of problems like eye strain when you
can't focus on stuff or headaches or in
my case trouble sleeping because i spend
a lot of time on the computer but
fortunately for you and me alike
gmg performance eyeglasses are here to
save the day and our eyes oh what's that
you notice i just put on a pair of the
newest generation of gmg optimizer
performance glasses proven to be more
effective against blue light resistance
than ever before
you're pretty observant no joke though
i've been using these for about a week
now and i can definitely tell the
difference in the way that my eyes and
brain feel after gaming or working for
hours on end like i do and they're so
high quality that i don't even notice a
difference in screen color unlike you
know night mode on your iphone or
something like that plus they look
pretty cool and come in a super snazzy
case i don't know i just feel very
classy wearing them if you're interested
in doing your eyes a favor now and for
the future then click the link in the
description below for a huge exclusive
40
off offer that's only good for the next
48 hours from
now that's almost half off and it's only
good for two days so don't sleep on this
then now onto the video
hey everyone bandit here you know i'm
pretty sure the legend of zelda will
outlive me it's a franchise that has so
much going for it that sets it up for
unlimited amounts of success i mean here
we are what 36 years into its life and
its sales numbers and community are at
an all-time high i hope i'll be at an
all-time high when i'm 36 i think this
is because zelda has done a whole lot
right over the years it's got the iconic
character design set in the immersive
world of hyrule full of diverse
inhabitants and monsters and dungeons
and it's been so successful in its
formula that it even inspired countless
game franchises over the years like the
soulsborne series which just came out
with eldon ring but one of the biggest
reasons for zelda's longevity is i think
in its vastly developed lore that
spreads out amongst the games letting
fans of the series theorize and connect
the dots between titles sometimes even
where dots are not meant to be connected
but anyway since there are so many new
people to the franchise these days i
wanted to make a video covering not
theories themselves but 10 of the most
intriguing factual lore discoveries
across all of the games that spawn
theories and or discussions as a result
of their intriguing natures and before
we get into it i wanted to say as a
heads up that this is regarding a nearly
four decade old franchise which means
that there is a possibility that you've
heard all of these before but there's
also the possibility that you haven't
only one way to find out first up we
have the intriguing open-ended fact that
the zelda universe is a multiverse see
this is proven by the third timeline in
the zelda franchise the fallen timeline
to be exact it isn't actually a timeline
well at least not in the same terms as
the other two buckle your seat belts
we're about to have a timeline
discussion see the adult and child
timelines are related to one another
based off of an event that happens no
matter what at the end of ocarina of
time zelda uses the power of the ocarina
of time to send link back in time to a
timeline where he prevents the events of
the adult timeline from happening this
spawns the new child timeline while the
original princess zelda lives on in the
adult timeline this is factually an
event that happened for both timelines
in one link disappeared after defeating
ganondorf and in the other link appeared
before ganondorf ever became ruler the
link between the timelines no pun
intended is that there is only one link
between the two timelines the hero of
time there is not an adult timeline here
of time that is separate from the child
timeline here of time they're both the
same individual which connects the
timelines together literally if that
makes sense one cannot exist without the
other however the fallen timeline on the
other hand features another hero of time
that died hence the word fallen in
contrast this is not an event that
happens no matter what this is what we
refer to as an if statement if link dies
then the fallen timeline occurs and
while yes it is another timeline more
specifically it's another reality
entirely this follows the real-life
assumption that choices spawn alternate
realities like for instance if i decided
to say look at them pancakes instead of
wow nice pancakes there are different
realities where i said either of those
the comic book universes like dc and
marvel are huge fans of this kind of
multiple dimension logic and with the
fallen timeline being based off of
solely the possibility that link could
be defeated but yet also being a
timeline that has multiple canonical
games taking place in it it proves to us
that the zelda universe is without a
doubt a multiverse which means that who
knows what other universes could be out
there maybe there's a universe where
ganondorf is the hero and link is the
villain but i've spent too long on this
point time to move on number two the
hero of skies aka link and skyward sword
aka the first link in the series is
actually not the first link in the
series from a canonical standpoint
throughout the game there are several
references to the goddess's chosen hero
who was around in the time when the
goddess hylia herself walked the earth
long before the first zelda even some
people claim that this is actually the
hero of the skies when he goes back in
time which he does at several different
points in the game but unfortunately
that can't be the case see when zelda
gives link the sail cloth after the wing
ceremony she straight up tells you that
the sail cloth she gives to you is not
the same as the cell cloth given to the
chosen hero of long ago and to me that's
well that's proof enough so yeah
intriguing lore discovery number two
there is another link the first link
that we've not yet seen in any game
hopefully one day we'll get a zelda
title about the events that truly
started it all the goddess hylia and the
original war against demise next up the
great deku tree is not the only great
tree in the series and i'm not just
talking about the other iterations of
the great deku tree in the oracle games
seasons and ages link is actually
transported outside of hyrule to the
world's holodrum and labrina
respectively in either of these worlds
there is a guardian tree called the maku
tree and in oracle of seasons it's a guy
and an oracle of ages it's a gal they
are of course very instrumental in
learning about the new worlds that link
has to adventure through but what's most
interesting to me about their existence
is that this means the great deku tree
is simply one great tree spirit of many
but how many good question maybe the
giant tree husks of breath of the wild
could shed some light on it number four
speaking of guys and gals remember that
little blond-haired kokiri girl from the
kokiri forest of ocarina of time fedo or
faro was her name or should i say their
name see farah reappears in the wind
waker as a kokiri ancestor to the korok
named makar the koroks are the
descendants evolution of the kokiri just
in case anyone didn't know that what's
more interesting though is that this is
probably even the same photo as the one
from ocarina of time since the prima
guide for the wind waker states that
this photo was a personal friend to the
hero of time and since kokiri are
immortal and don't die from old age
because they don't age so unless someone
killed fodo from ocarina of time and
another kokiri was born created and was
also a blondie named fodo but just a guy
instead this means that this is either
the same photo or a reincarnation
meaning photo is either gender fluid or
transsexual photo is also in the child
timeline where they pop up there as a
guy again in link's home village of
ordon interesting isn't it and since
we're on the topic of gender and whatnot
let's just continue on why don't we
number next is that by the time breath
of the wild takes place as many fans
noticed there seems to be an alarming
lack of male gerudo presence there are
theories about some people namely this
hylian merchant possibly being garuda
males but those are theories and are
unfortunately unconfirmed what's also
not confirmed is the assumption that
many fans have about gerudo men no
longer existing by the time of breath of
the wild this assumption comes from both
the lack of them in game and the
supplementary literature called
masterworks creating a champion where
the developers of breath of the wild
state quite clearly that the gerudo only
give birth to females and that there has
not been a gerudo king since the days of
ganondorf however it does also clearly
acknowledge the fact that male gerudos
did in fact used to be born into the
gerudo race albeit rarely with no event
having happened that would prevent the
males from being born anymore it's
entirely possible that there have still
been gerudo men being born once every
hundred years since the days of
ganondorf but that they haven't been
allowed to live in gerudo town or
haven't been given the throne since you
know ganondorf in fact this is even
probable since we can see that there is
gerudo male armor being created and sold
in the gerudo secret club for there to
be a merchant there has to be consumers
so wouldn't it make sense if gerudo men
were still a thing albeit a secret thing
not allowed in their own town or maybe
they are and maybe the garuda women are
not always what they seem six is the
intriguing fact that right before breath
of the wild on the timeline in the
fallen timeline there were two princess
zeldas alive at the same time no joke in
the original legend of zelda link
rescues princess zelda from the clutches
of ganon and in zelda 2 the adventure of
link he has to once again rescue a
princess zelda but this time it's
different after the events of the first
game as link approaches his 16th
birthday the mark of the triforce
appears on his hand zelda's guardian
impa then reveals to him that there is a
slumbering princess zelda known at the
time as princess zelda the first who has
had a spell cast upon her to sleep
eternally kind of a lot like sleeping
beauty if you think about it the only
way to save her and awaken her from her
magical slumber is for link to obtain
the missing triforce of courage and
unite the three pieces to form the
ultimate alarm clock and wake the
princess up at the end of the game you
do in fact wake her up and she may or
may not kiss link as the curtain falls
that's the you know debatable maybe
they're just going in for a friendly
side hug anyway the fact that the
princess zelda from the first game is
still alive and kicking in the kingdom
of hyrule and the princess zelda of long
ago wakes up at the end of zelda 2 means
that there are quite literally two
zeldas of the bloodline of the goddess
alive at this present point in time in
the game immediately preceding breath of
the wild kind of crazy the more you
think about it i mean does this mean
that there are now two royal bloodlines
i don't know but it's intriguing
nonetheless next up is about midna or
rather midna's helmet you know that
piece of the fused shadow relic that
just so happens to fit atop her rather
large cranium the helmet itself has long
been the source of tons of speculation
and theorizing because of the eye
present on the part that covers up
midna's eye it looks almost exactly like
the majora's mascara prompting many
people to believe many different things
about its origin however if you flip the
helmet over you can actually see another
symbol on its back and this one is
pretty clearly the sheikah symbol
complete with those signature three
eyelash thingies anyone who's anyone in
the zelda theory realm knows that
symbology is extremely important to the
series as far as understanding what the
hell is going on so for the sheikah
symbol to pop up here pretty much
confirms that the shika had something to
do with the fused shadow's creation i
wonder what it could be number eight is
that for an iconic weapon that's very
closely associated with the series and
the character of link himself the true
master sword has actually only appeared
in fewer than half of all the zelda
titles out there even though link
himself appears in all of them and i
specify the true master sword because
there are some appearances in the series
that feature not the master sword itself
but rather swords that link uses
becoming as powerful as the master sword
and subsequently being referred to as
just the master sword the true actual
legitimate master sword only appears in
games that follow a specific pattern and
that pattern is ganon no not my dog the
other ganon and if you want it to be
technical it would be to eliminate
demise or the curse of demise's demon
tribe or perhaps to even fight against
the power of the triforce of power but
the point still stands that the master
sword only shows up in games where link
is fighting against ganondorf ganon or
demise which is less than half of them
this means that the sword has a specific
purpose and would rather not be used for
just regular you know pot smashing and
the like and it gives credence to this
text from breath of the wild concerning
the blade of evil's bane 9 in the
mysterious land of hyrule the spirit of
the hero reincarnates to defeat evil but
he's not the only spirit to reincarnate
time and time again and i'm not talking
about zelda either we've also got beedle
who's shown up in six different games
tingle who's also shown up in six
different games and impa who's been in
eight different zelda games possibly
nine since link's reincarnations across
the series have always been explained as
due to the spirit of the hero being tied
to the land of hyrule then the same
logic must be used for the others this
must mean that there are other
reincarnating spirits also tied to the
land of hyrule such as the spirit of the
merchant for beetle and the spirit of
the oh let's call him the spirit of the
child for tingle and the spirit of the
guardian for impa they don't all have as
big or important of a role to play as
link but they are all roles that aid
link or zelda in the fight against evil
nonetheless finally at number 10 and
speaking of reincarnation most people
know that ganondorf's multiple
appearances are due to the splitting of
the timelines but in reality he's just
the same person every time but some
people might not know that there has
actually been canonically on the
timeline another ganondorf entirely in
four swords adventures which takes place
in the child timeline following the
events of twilight princess which ended
with ganondorf's death another ganondorf
is born and becomes another ganon
strangely enough though the master sword
does not make an appearance in this game
and the four sword is all that's needed
to defeat this new ganon but another
discovery that adds some interesting
flavor to this would be a section of cut
dialogue from the game twilight princess
you remember at the end of the game when
ganondorf monologues a bit before his
death well he was actually supposed to
go on for quite a bit about the curse of
the demon tribe and how a member of his
bloodline would always appear every time
the world brings forth those marked with
the crests of the triforce the point is
ganondorf is or was initially supposed
to be a similar kind of reincarnating
spirit whose bloodline would produce
other ganondorfs apparently which is
kind of problematic when you're trying
to you know defeat evil once and for all
makes you think that ganondorf may have
been telling us the truth and that all
of this might just be a loop eternally
destined to repeat over and over again
as ordained by the gods themselves in
order to maintain balance but depressing
talk of futility aside that's the list
10 intriguing discoveries and
realizations within zelda lore that can
each easily lead to countless theories
and speculations were they new to you
did you know all of them or perhaps do
you know of more intriguing discoveries
let me know in the comments below also
thank you so much for watching please
consider leaving a like on the video if
you enjoyed it or at least my efforts in
making it and subscribe for the love of
hylia subscribe if you haven't already
because listen this is the place to be
for interesting videos about your
favorite games alright you're gonna want
to stick around i want you to stick
around i need friends anyway also as
always huge thanks to my bandit crew all
of which are beautiful beautiful
creatures who enable me to create these
videos and go above and beyond with
their support no matter the tier that's
all i've got for this one so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day this is bandit looking forward to
seeing you next time and signing out
hey guys it's me again you know on
camera real life bandit i'm back and no
this isn't another promo segment this is
just me checking in and saying
hey and also i feel like i need to say a
few things to you my peoples first off i
want to thank you guys all of you for
still being here after what happened
recently with the channel if you're
watching this and you've been here for
more than
two or three months then you know that i
have recently rebranded masked nintendo
bandit is now a legacy name which is
extremely bittersweet to say and even
think about if you're still confused as
to why i made this decision to rebrand
please feel free to check out the video
that i made about the decision i'll link
to it in the description below i go into
a lot more detail about why in a
nutshell though i just thought that it
was no longer worth it to not be myself
on my own channel at one point i thought
it would be okay but i no longer think
it's worth it to abstain from talking
about all the games that i myself
personally am into for personal reasons
for mental health reasons even for
youtube algorithm reasons it just seemed
like the best choice of action course of
action i didn't say that right and i'll
admit that when i was only ever covering
the legend of zelda i was hurting all of
those categories and now for the first
time on the channel
i finally feel free
to actually cover
whatever i want to and it is such a
powerful
amazing feeling but that being said i
wanted to pop up on screen
look you guys in the eyes and clarify
once and for all very very very clearly
to the people in the back of the room to
the front of the room
whatever that i
am not done
with zelda okay i see your comments that
pop up on my elden ring videos on my
delta rune videos on my whatever other
videos that i have done and will
continue to do that are not zelda i see
them the whole bandit are you done with
zelda bandit oh i i'm here for zelda
where where is the zelda content
guys first off if you're leaving those
comments i can already tell that you
didn't watch my video explaining the
rebrand but that's okay i wanted to
reassure all of you that i am not and
will never be done with making content
that is about the legend of zelda let me
play that part for you again that i am
not and will never be done with making
content that is about the legend of
zelda i can't it's my favorite franchise
it has literally shaped who i am it gave
birth to this channel all i'm doing is
simply branching into the other games
and franchises that i've always been
into in addition to zelda zelda will
undoubtedly be front and center on the
channel again once we have anything
substantial about the sequel or of
course when the sequel itself releases
but
zelda will never again be the only thing
that i cover i'm not covering eldon ring
as a kind of temporary hold to get me to
breath of the wild too i'm covering
eldon ring because i want to cover eldon
ring and you can take that explanation
and copy paste it on whatever other game
franchise i will be covering on this
channel i'm going to be delving into
lore i'm going to be
doing reviews and opinion pieces about
all sorts of things halo assassins creed
whatever i want to in addition to zelda
and i am so
so very excited to take you guys along
this journey with me but that being said
i completely understand if that is not
something that you want to stick around
for so to summarize this little mini
ramble that i wanted to stick in here at
the end of the video one you guys amaze
me thank you so much for sticking with
the channel and helping it to grow even
more after the rebrand two i will never
ever ever ever ever be done with zelda
don't even think about it but i do
understand if it rubbed you the wrong
way when i branched out and three
this channel's evolution has only just
begun trust me on that
and four i i love you all anyway back to
the outro this is bandit looking forward
to seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you